what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and i was fortunate enough to
get a hands-on experience with eldon
ring i was able to play the first
roughly seven hours of the game and even
went beyond where the network test ended
so i wanted to make a video about 12
interesting things i learned i think
it's going to go without saying that
there will be slight spoilers but like
you i know there are things i would hate
if they were spoiled for me so i'm going
to do my best to avoid anything like
that
bandai namco has been slowly revealing
the starting classes of alden ring the
current ones available as of my time
with the game were vagabond warrior hero
bandit astrologer prophet samurai
prisoner confessor and wretch with
wretch being the level 1 build
but just like any prior souls born game
your starting class is just that if you
don't like your stats every level up is
a chance to build your character in
another direction like adding more
strength to go full on strength build or
adding various magic stats if you want
to use some spells
every souls born game has had a rest
area where npcs gather and you can feel
a little bit of safety the roundtable
hold is eldon ring's version of this and
it isn't immediately available to the
player but once you do gain access to it
similar to the hub of other games npcs
will wander in and out of the area with
certain parts of the round table hold
being closed off until an event opens up
more places you can access
as far as i can tell this hub is
completely unreachable without warping
but who knows if that will change
through the network test we discovered
that estus flasks worked similarly to
dark souls 3. you'll have an hp recovery
estus flask and an fp recovery estus
flask with fp being focus points or the
way you can utilize magic and weapon
arts again like dark souls 3 you'll have
a total number of estes uses that you
can delegate between the two however you
like and in whatever way is best for
your build you'll also be able to
upgrade your estus flasks which will be
extremely useful as you reach more
challenging areas the way to do this is
with various seeds you'll find
throughout the game
golden seas are your way to upgrade the
number of flask uses you have and you
can find golden seeds a number of
different ways while you're probably
familiar with the massive herb trees
from the elton ring trailer there are
various sized herd trees with tiny ones
having golden seeds underneath them when
you first find them additionally there
are other ways to get your hands on
golden seeds including npc quest lines
as you level up your estus flask you'll
slowly need a larger number of golden
seeds for later upgrades in order to
upgrade the strength of your estus flask
and just how much it heals you you'll
need another kind of seed these seeds
can be found at various churches if
you've seen footage of the network test
you'll know about the church of dragon
communion players we're able to find
there are many other kinds of churches
and this is where i was able to find
this kind of seed in my experience
that said there may be other places to
find them this is just what i was able
to find in my short playthrough
one of the critiques of eldon ring has
been the game's spirit ashes there are
various spirit allies you can summon to
aid you in battle the critique mainly
comes from the network test and feeling
like these spirits were too powerful
however in the build i played there were
a number of ways their power was offset
we learned from the network test that
for one you can only summon these
spirits in special marked areas and they
aren't available anytime you want for
example i don't believe i was able to
summon them in the game's ever jails
additionally and this is probably the
most important point the spirits start
off relatively weak they'll also cost a
different amount of fp to summon and i
found a higher powered spirit that i
didn't have enough fp to summon in my
time playing the game
you can however level up your spirit
ashes similar to how you would upgrade a
weapon
in order to do so you'll need to find a
spirit tuner who will take grave glove
words you can find that as you'd imagine
work just like a blacksmith upgrading
your weapons with smithing stones
while i didn't specifically find ways to
upgrade armor in my short time playing
there was a sewing kit i found in the
game which allows you to customize your
armor it was hard for me to tell if this
was purely cosmetic or if there were
genuine stat differences but it's
something to keep in mind and keep an
eye out for i also found a painting that
you could not only look at but collect i
have no idea what the purpose is or if
it's going to be something like what
we've seen from dark souls 1 or 3 but
it's definitely an interesting new
feature
eldon ring definitely still has items
that are related to pvp i found a couple
mirrors which let you alter your
appearance in minor ways in order to
trick invaders into attempting to kill
the wrong player
one of my personal concerns in playing
the other ring network test was that
outside of the legacy dungeons all of
the other dungeons felt pretty barren
and small they felt a little more like
mini chalice dungeons than other areas
we've come to known from software games
that said in playing the full build of
the game i stumbled upon a far larger
dungeon that wasn't considered a legacy
dungeon it helps show that there will be
a wide variety of dungeon sizes you'll
find in eldon ring from larger to medium
sized and absolutely tiny mini dungeons
additionally all of these dungeons had
unique bosses with interesting loot to
find so from software is definitely
making exploration a worthwhile venture
in eldon ring
and speaking of dungeons let's talk
about legacy dungeons i had the
opportunity to play through stormville
and while i'm absolutely certain i
didn't see all of it i was able to make
it through godric and get a good feel of
the overall area stormville is massive
in scope and has plenty of different
wraparounds and interesting areas to
explore as you're not allowed to use
torrent your spectral steed and dungeons
it truly felt like a classic from
software experience if i were to compare
it to anything think of it like demon
souls imagine that you have boletaria
latria and the rest of the areas all
available in the game however instead of
needing to return to a hub to access
these areas the full map of the realm is
yours to explore and you'll stumble
across boletaria you'll stumble across
latria size and scope-wise is hard to
tell just how large all of the legacy
dungeons will be so i honestly can't
tell you if the aries will be more akin
to the cathedral of the deep or irithyll
the boreal valley in size or something
as large as scale as boletaria or latria
going back to dark souls 2 there were
unique items in that game called
ferris's lockstones these lockstones
unlocked special areas that had special
goodies hidden away they were one time
use so it was up to you to find more of
these lockstones so you could unlock
every hidden area
alden ring has an item that works in the
exact same way called a stone sword key
there's plenty of variety in what's
behind these keys including locked away
ever jails areas with hidden treasures
and even dungeons
something interesting and brand new to
eldon ring was the way in which you seem
to unlock the game's accessories or
charms while you start the game with one
of these slots after defeating a certain
boss just by defeating that boss i
automatically unlocked one of these
slots i can't say for certain how many
slots you'll gain or if this is how
every slot will be unlocked but it's
definitely an interesting change that's
worth noting
the lore of the game that has been
revealed to us has made it clear how
important great runes are to the story
in fact the way you level up in the game
is by finding basic runes they act like
your souls or blood echoes from souls
born games in being both your form of
currency and way to level up
like those games you'll gain them for
defeating enemies or finding special
items that will give you rooms for using
them
great runes on the other hand are unique
equippable items you'll be able to find
that grant you specific blessings and
abilities i don't want to ruin which i
found or what it did but it's an
interesting thing to note
once you make it outside the tutorial
area and into limgrave the world truly
is your oyster there are definitely
smarter and easier paths the game pushes
you into taking
but you can seemingly go wherever you
want right away it's a refreshing and
different experience and as exploration
seems to be well handled in eldon ring
it's certainly shaping up to be a game
that will be incredible to explore
and there you have 12 things i learned
playing elton ring i hope you learned
something that interested you and i
answered some questions you might have
february 25th cannot come soon enough
and i can't wait to see all you lowly
tarnish soon
[Music]
you